tonight we are welcoming Chris Hedges
chris has been a foreign correspondent
for 15 years he's on the staff at the
New York Times and was a member of the
team that won the 2002 Pulitzer Prize
for exploited explanatory reporting for
the papers coverage of global terrorism
Chris Hedges has been um excuse me I'm
sorry
he has also worked for the Dallas
Morning News Christian Science Monitor
and National Public Radio he holds a
Master of Divinity from Harvard
University he is the author of losing
Moses on the freeway the Ten
Commandments in America what every
person should know about war and war is
a force that gives us meaning tonight
his he is talking about his newest book
American fascist the right the Christian
right and the war on America please join
me in welcoming Chris Hedges thank you
dr. James Luther Adams my ethics
professor at Harvard Divinity School
told us that when we were his age and he
was then close to 80 we would all be
fighting the Christian fascists the
warning given to me 25 years ago came at
the moment Pat Robertson and other radio
and tell of an Julis began speaking
about a new political religion that
would direct its efforts at taking
control of all institutions including
mainstream denominations and the
government its stated goal was to use
the United States to create a global
Christian Empire it was hard at the time
to take such fantastic rhetoric
seriously especially given the
buffoonish quality of those who
expounded it but Adams warned us against
the blindness caused by intellectual
snobbery the Nazis he said we're not
going to return with swastikas and brown
shirts their ideological inheritors had
found a mask for fascism in patriotism
and the pages of the Bible Adams was not
a man to use the word fascist lightly he
was in Germany in 1930
five and 1936 and worked with the
underground anti-nazi Church known as
the confessing Church led by Dietrich
Bonhoeffer Adams was eventually detained
and interrogated by the Gestapo who
suggested he might want to consider
returning to the United States it was a
suggestion he followed he left on a
night train with framed portraits of
Adolf Hitler placed over the contents
inside his suitcase to hide the roles of
home movie film he took of the so called
German Christian Church which was
pro-nazi and the few individuals who
defied them including the theologians
Karl Bart and Albert Schweitzer the ruse
worked when the border police lifted the
top of the suitcases saw the portraits
of the fear and closed them up again
I watched hours of the grainy black and
white films as he narrated in his
apartment in Cambridge he saw in the
Christian Right long before we did
disturbing similarities with the German
Christian Church and the Nazi Party
similarities that he said would in the
event of prolonged social instability or
a national crisis see American fascists
under the guise of religion rise to
dismantle the open society he despaired
of liberals who he said as in Nazi
Germany mouthed silly platitudes about
dialogue and inclusiveness that made
them ineffectual and impotent liberals
he said did not understand the power and
a lure of evil nor the cold reality of
how the world worked
the current hand-wringing by Democrats
with many asking how they can reach out
to a movement whose leaders brand them
is demonic and satanic would not have
surprised Adams like Bonhoeffer he did
not believe that those would fight
effectively in coming times of turmoil a
fight that for him was an integral part
of the biblical message would come from
the church or the liberal secular elite
his critique of the prominent research
universities
along with the media was no less
withering these institutions
self-absorbed compromised by their close
relationship with government and
corporations given enough of the pie to
be complacent were unwilling to deal
with the fundamental moral questions and
inequities of the age they had no
stomach for a battle that might cost
them their prestige and comfort he told
me I suspect half ingest that if the
Nazis took over America 60% of the
Harvard faculty would begin their
lectures with the Nazi salute but this
too was not an abstraction he had
watched academics at the University of
Heidelberg including the philosopher
Martin Heidegger raised their arms
stiffly to students before class Adams
also reminded us that American
intellectuals and industrialists openly
flirted with fascism in the 1930s
Mussolini's corporatism which created an
unchecked industrial and business
aristocracy appealed to many American
industrialists at the time who saw it as
an effective counterweight to the New
Deal in 1934 Fortune magazine lavished
praise on the Italian dictator for his
defanging of labor unions and his
empowerment of industrialists at the
expense of workers Adams finally told us
to watch closely what the Christian
Right did to homosexuals he had seen how
the Nazis had used values to launch
state repression of opponents Hitler
days after he took power in 1933 imposed
a ban on all homosexual and lesbian
organizations
he ordered raids on places where
homosexuals gathered culminating with a
ransacking of the Institute for sexual
science in Berlin thousands of volumes
from the Institute's library were tossed
into a bonfire Adams said that
homosexuals would be the first deviance
singled out by the Christian
we would be the next the ban on same-sex
marriages passed by 11 states was part
of this march towards our door a 1996
federal law already defines marriage as
between a man and a woman all of the
states with these ballot measures with
the exception of Oregon had out log
same-sex marriages as do 27 other states
the bans however had to be passed
believers were told to thwart activist
judges who wanted to overturn them the
Christian family even the nation was
under threat the bans served to widen
the splits tearing apart our country the
attacks on homosexuals handed to the
foot soldiers of the Christian Right an
easy target it gave them a taste of
victory it made them feel empowered but
it is ominous for gays and for us two
decades later even in the face of the
growing reach of the Christian Right
Adams prediction seems apocalyptic and
yet the power brokers in the Christian
Right have moved from the fringes of
society to the executive branch the
House of Representatives the Senate and
the courts the movement has seized
control of the Republican Party and
holds a majority of seats in 36% of all
Republican Party state committees or 18
of 50 states along with large minorities
and 81% of the rest of the states 45
senators and a hundred and eighty six
members of the House of Representatives
earned between an eighty to a hundred
percent approval rating from the three
most influential Christian Right
advocacy groups the Christian Coalition
Eagle Forum and Family Resource Council
the movement is making a huge push to
seize control of key states including
Ohio where a group called patriot
pastors have adopted as their symbol the
cross superimposed on the American flag
when I attended a
of patriot pastors in Dayton a chorus
sang militant hymns and patriotic songs
while the crowd watched pictures of the
war in Iraq they must maintain the
fiction of the separation of church and
state
dodging their intent to build a
theocratic Christian government while at
the same time sending out a stream of
coded reassurances to their radical base
the movement has signed on dozens of
cities and numerous states such as Ohio
to a movement that will build people of
what they call high character Ohio is
now a state of character the state has
put funding and resources aside to Train
citizens and leaders on how to be people
of character and potential candidates
can fill out forums to declare they are
persons of character and their names are
posted on the website but woven into the
20 point list which I urge you all to
read one which deftly eschews all
religious terminology is a blueprint for
an authoritarian state when were
questioning power is unpatriotic and
only those with high character as
rigidly defined by Christians in the
radical Christian right have the right
to lead and be heard individualism the
right to privacy the belief that other
political viewpoints and moral systems
have value are all attacked as
disruptive to social cohesion in the
section titled unity followers are told
high character people strive to build
relationships that foster oneness among
others who are bound with them to a
common promise vision mission or purpose
ethical organizations seek uniformity in
their people's shared character ethics
and unity among their otherwise richly
diverse people without a preserving
commitment to shared character ethics
there is no hope for sustainable unity
in a section titled accountability it
talks about how to enforce this unity
high character people scrutinize
themselves and welcome the scrutiny of
others ethical people acknowledge that
human nature compels us toward
independence our preference for
independence results in isolation from
one another
isolation breeds temptation to unethical
conduct ethical people resist this chain
reaction by adopting transparent life
and work styles that invite inspection
ethical people place themselves in
relationships that motivate
self-examination and encourage
constructive critique from others
particularly those they serve in the
section called honoring Authority there
is a reminder that without moral guides
people of high character go astray and
deviate from the ethical standards
imposed from above all people are
imperfect it reads requiring boundaries
for behavior high character people
willingly yield to the authority of
those who are charged with upholding
those boundaries ethical people help
shape and then abide by the legitimate
laws rules and boundaries established by
legitimate authorities and strive to
live within those boundaries for the
betterment of all people when those
given Authority violate conscience
convicting ethics ethical people take
ethical action to restore ethical
Authority and towards the end of the
list under the heading our ability to
change there is a section titled
submission to truth truth transforms
people only when we submit to it truly
high character people cannot not
transform eventually everyone ultimately
confronts the power of truth when
confronted by the truth ethical people
are
convinced to replace or put off their
unethical behavior by pursuing and
putting on ethical beliefs unethical
people do not this ongoing replacement
lifestyle of ethical people produces the
enduring evidences called
virtues all these points make in essence
the same point people of high character
give overall Authority for moral and
political decisions to leaders who tell
them what is true and what is right all
must if they have high character invite
scrutiny by these leaders by the organs
of the state and by their neighbors
these tenants are the cornerstone of the
police state the state where all are
told to watch for social and political
deviance where there is only one
Orthodox truth where all dissent is
heresy where people who are not of high
character people who do not submit and
do what they are told are not allowed to
contaminate the public domain those of
high character those who abide by these
moral tenants become servile afraid
bound to the tasks laid out by their
leaders willing to be punished for
failing to achieve the moral standards
and goals imposed by the state and ready
to denounce those around them it is the
antithesis of the message Jesus preached
in the Gospels President Bush must
further these objectives including the
March to turn education and social
welfare over to these churches with his
faith-based initiative which has handed
hundreds of millions of taxpayer dollars
to these organizations as well as chip
away at the wall between church and
state with his judicial appointments if
he does not want to face a revolt within
his core constituency Hope has two
beautiful daughters Augustine wrote
their names are anger and courage anger
at the way things are encouraged to see
that they do not remain the way they are
anger when directed against those who
would abuse the weak preach bigotry and
injustice trample on the poor crush
dissent and impose a religious tyranny
is a blessing read the prophets but
because so many of our liberal
institutions are bankrupt bought off by
corporate dollars no longer willing to
accept in religious terms that heretics
exist the goal is to appease the very
people who openly call for our
destruction the liberal church stumbles
along
muttering Creed's they no longer believe
trying to peddle a fuzzy feel-good
theology that distorts and ignores the
Bible often as much as the Christian
right and the Christian Right is not
always wrong about liberals in fact the
movement voices much of our most
prescient social criticism they
understand the ills of American society
even as they use these ills to plunge us
into tyranny they grasp the hollowness
timidity and hypocrisy of the liberal
church the Christian Right attacks
cultural relativism the creed that there
is no absolute good in all value systems
have equal merit even as they benefit in
a final irony from those who tolerate
them in the name of cultural relativism
the most potent opposition to the
movement will rise I expect from within
the evangelical tradition itself and the
movement fears Christians who have
remained loyal to the core values of the
gospel who delineate between right and
wrong who are willing to be vilified and
attacked in the name of a higher good
and who have the courage to fight back
most liberals the movement is figured
out whilst and complacently to be
sheared like sheep attempting to open
dialogues and reach out their hands to
those who spit venom in their face Karl
Popper in the first volume of the
enemies of the open society
rights of what he calls the paradox of
tolerance unlimited tolerance he says
must lead to the disappearance of
tolerance if we extend unlimited
tolerance even to those who are
intolerant if we are not prepared to
defend a tolerant society against the
onslaught of the intolerant
then the tolerant will be destroyed and
tolerance with them in this formulation
I do not imply for instance that we
should always suppress the utterance of
intolerant philosophies as long as we
can counter them by rational argument
and keep them in check by public opinion
suppression would certainly be most
unwise but we should claim the right to
suppress them if necessary by force for
it may easily turn out that they are not
prepared to meet us on the level of
rational argument but begin by
denouncing all argument they may forbid
their followers to listen to rational
argument because it is deceptive and
teach them to answer arguments by the
use of their fists or pistols we should
therefore claim in the name of tolerance
the right not to tolerate the intolerant
we should claim that any movement
preaching intolerance places itself
outside the law and we should consider
incitement to intolerance and
persecution as criminal in the same way
as we should consider incitement to
murder or kidnapping or the revival of
the slave trade as criminal the
Christian Right has no religious
legitimacy it is a mass political
movement it ignores the core values of
the Christian religion summed up by
Jesus in the Sermon on the Mount and the
core values of American democracy they
are as the Reverend William Sloane
coffin said not biblical literalists as
they claim but selectively literalists
choosing bits and pieces of the Bible
that conform to their ideology and
bigotry and ignoring
distorting or making up the rest we must
begin to support those isolated groups
and individuals who had some cost are
fighting back the clergy and rabbis who
have banded together in Ohio to
challenge in court the tax-exempt status
of the mega churches that peddle this
ideology and promote Christian
candidates the independent judges such
as the Republican appointed judge in
Dover Pennsylvania who banned the
teaching of creationism in the public
school because it is mythology not
science as well as Cardinal Roger Mahony
the head of the Archdiocese of Los
Angeles the nation's largest who called
on Catholics to be prepared to defy
efforts in Congress backed by the
Religious Right to make it a felony to
shield or protect or offer support to
illegal immigrants this bill would
expand the definition of alien smuggling
to theoretically include working in a
soup kitchen driving a friend to a bus
stop or caring for a neighbor's child it
would make Mercy compassion and charity
for the least among us a federal crime
in Mark Twain's book The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn
it ends with Huck facing the moral
dilemma we face whether to pay homage to
a false moral code or damn ourselves in
the eyes of many by opposing it so I was
full of trouble full as I could be and I
didn't know what to do at last I had an
idea and I says I'll go and write the
letter and then see if I can pray why it
was astonishing the way I felt as light
as a feather right straight off and my
troubles all gone so I got a piece of
paper and a pencil all glad and excited
and sat down and wrote miss Watson your
runaway Negro Jim is down here two mile
below Pikesville and mr. Phelps has got
him and he will give him up for the
reward if you send Huck Finn I felt good
an all washed clean of sin for the first
time I had ever felt so in my life and I
knowed I
pray now but I didn't do it straight off
but laid the paper down and set their
thinking thinking how good it was all
this happened so and how near I come to
being lost and going to hell and went on
thinking and got to thinking over our
trip down the river and I see Jim before
me all the time in the day and in the
nighttime sometimes moonlight sometimes
storms and we are floating along talking
and singing and laughing but somehow I
couldn't seem to strike no places to
harden me against him but only the other
kind I'd see him standing my watch on
top of his'n
instead of calling me so I could go on
sleeping and see how glad he was when I
come back out of the fog and when I come
to him again in the swamp up there where
the feud was and suchlike times and
would always call me honey and pet me
and do everything he could think of for
me and how good he always was and at
last I struck the time I saved him by
telling the men we had smallpox aboard
and he was so grateful and said I was
the best friend old Jim ever had in the
world and the only one he's got now and
then I happened to look around and see
that paper it was a closed place I took
it up and held it in my hand I was a
trembling because I'd got to decide
forever betwixt two things and I knowed
it I studied a minute sort of holding my
breath and then says to myself alright
then I'll go to hell and tore it up I do
not deny the right of these Christian
radicals to be to believe in worship as
they choose but I will not engage in a
dialogue with those who deny my right to
be who d legitimize my faith and
denounce my struggle before God as
worthless old dialog must include
respect and tolerance for the belief
Worth and dignity of others including
those outside the nation and the faith
when this respect is denied it is no
longer a difference of opinion
it is a fight for survival this movement
seeks in the name of Christianity and
American democracy to destroy that which
it claims to defend I do not believe
that America will inevitably become a
fascist state or that the Christian
Right is the Nazi Party but I do believe
that the Christian Right is a sworn and
potent enemy of the open society its
ideology bears within it the seeds of a
religious fascism in the event of a
crisis in the event of another
catastrophic terrorist attack an
economic meltdown or huge environmental
disaster the movement stands poised to
ruthlessly reshape America in ways that
have not been seen since the nation's
founding all Americans not only those of
faith must learn to speak about this
movement with a new vocabulary to give
up passivity and to defend tolerance the
attacks by this movement on the rights
and beliefs of Muslims Jews immigrants
gays lesbians women scholars scientists
those they dismiss as nominal Christians
and those they brand with a curse of
secular humanists is an attack on all of
us on our values our religious freedoms
and our democracy tolerance is a virtue
but tolerance coupled with passivity is
a vice thank
I think we have time for questions if
anyone has any it all encouraged by the
midterm elections the question is
whether I feel encouraged by the midterm
elections certainly it's encouraging for
me the engine of the movement is
personal in economic despair
and that's the engine of all
totalitarian movements that's not an
original thought fritz Stern wrote about
this in the politics of cultural despair
Hana arrant wrote about this in the
origins of totalitarianism Karl Popper
understood this and what we have done
over the last few decades is
disenfranchise tens of millions of
people in this country there's been a
violation of the American working class
many of whom come from my own family
where they can no longer get jobs which
can sustain them in a dignified and
meaningful way and you go to some of the
former manufacturing centers as I have
over the last two years in places like
Ohio and the end of the world is no
longer an abstraction to these people
and and the disintegration of community
has brought with it the social ills the
disintegration of family addictions
domestic abuse schools that no longer
function coupled of course with a
removal of any kind of credible or
meaningful federal assistance and I
blame much of that on the Clinton
administration and we have we are left
in a situation where there is no check
on the creation of a rapacious American
oligarchy we now live in a country where
the top 1% of this nation controls more
wealth than the bottom 90% combined and
when you create those kind of economic
dislocations when you shunt these people
aside and they're largely invisible now
in in press that is controlled by these
corporations the result is political
deformation political distortions which
is exactly what the Christian Right is
because what the Christian Right does is
it removes them from a reality-based
world it gives them a non
reality-based belief system that gives
them a belief system in magic where
Jesus intervenes on a daily basis in
their life where God has a plan for them
where they are protected supported and
and once you remove and they enter and
we're talking about tens of millions of
people in this country once you remove
this number of people from a reality
based world and that of course is what
creationism is about it's not about an
alternative it is about the destruction
of science facts become interchangeable
with opinions lies become true facts
that are inconvenient are simply
discarded and ignored and that of course
is the very definition as George Orwell
understood of how a totalitarian society
works and the first thing totalitarian
movements do is they remove their own
their believers from the reality base
world by conjuring up a lying world of
consistency until they have the power to
shut those iron gates and impose that
world on the rest of us and there is no
hope to blunt to blunting this movement
until we step in and Riaan franchise
these people back into the society this
is a movement built on profound despair
and it just isn't a despair
unfortunately we have citizens have sat
by complacency complacently and allowed
to happen the world quite obviously got
a mahendra attitude toward Islam also do
you think that on those sentiments of
fuel by ideological differences of these
things political well the question is
about their the attitudes of people like
Pat Robertson to Islam well there's a
frightening demonization of everybody
who's outside the movement including
people of other faiths it's a binary
worldview black and white good and evil
and all of those who
do not submit to this movement and this
is of course when you look closely at
you know the the type of power structure
that they impose on their followers one
sees I think clearly on the on the micro
level the the authoritarian or despotic
quality of the movement in the family
unit the male is the undisputed head of
the household
the woman is subservient I mean people
like James Dobson not only call on women
to remove themselves from the workforce
and stay at home but to remove the
children from the public schools and the
role of the women is to essentially be
part of this indoctrinated process
through Christian homeschooling which is
of the I think 1.1 million people
homeschooled in this country I forget
the exact figure most of them are being
filled with this frightening
mythological vision of science American
history and everything else so there's a
demonization of everyone outside the
movement not just Muslims but but of
course Muslims become especially since
Armageddon will supposedly take place in
the Middle East a wonderful kind of foil
and I think that that that that what you
see with leaders like this is a
redirecting of that rage and that
yearning for violence especially
apocalyptic violence which they believe
will be a kind of cleansing of the
society a redirecting of that rage
giving people a moral license to hate
and even kill those who oppose them and
that's certainly what we're seeing in
the Middle East and in all apocalyptic
movements which essentially is what this
movement is play off
apocalyptic elements on the other side
so that and of course in many ways they
mirror each other so that you find
Islamic radicals in many ways mirroring
Christian radicals and I watched this
you know in places like the Balkans and
and what they do within their own
societies essentially destroy the center
destroy the moderate base within their
own society so that it becomes so
polarized and and just as
Fran you too Sherman the the dictator in
Croatia needed Slobodan Milosevic who
ran the Serbian nationalist movement out
of Serbia Milosevic needed to German you
need people with a similar binary
worldview a similar penchant for
violence to play off of each other and
destroy the centers within your own
societies that is happening in the
Muslim world but it's also happening
here in the United States a bush
administration relating to well the
religious right has gained tremendous
inroads in the Bush administration in
roads that they never had before there's
been a hijacking of government
scientific of reproductive rights
programs AIDS research
they've of course receive as I mentioned
hundreds of millions of dollars very
hard people have tried to pin down the
exact figure it's very hard to pin it
down but certainly you know I mean
taxpayers money is being given to Pat
Roberts Robertson's Operation Blessing
these people are getting big money and
uh certainly there was has been at least
up until the midterm elections an
attempt to politicize the judiciary by
putting in ideologically driven judges
we see it within the military we see
there's a huge push by the radical
Christian Right to take over the
chaplain cease and this isn't a matter
of presenting a particular religious
viewpoint it's about indoctrination it's
ultimately about the politicizing the
military itself so that and we if if you
go and look if you can find it because
it got yanked off their website and they
made youtube take it down but the
Christian embassy put out a video after
9/11 where they went to the Pentagon
they interviewed senior officials
Colonels generals in the military
talking about their commitment to Christ
talking about the proselytizing efforts
within the military and that coupled
with these mercenary groups that they
have created in Iraq 25,000
scenaries groups like Blackwater run by
Eric Prince you know a very secretive
multi-millionaire figure very close to
the Christian Right what we're seeing is
the effort to build a kind of Praetorian
Guard and I think for me one of the most
chilling moments in the aftermath of
Hurricane Katrina is when these
Blackwater operatives in their black
uniforms and wraparound sunglasses and
big SUVs and automatic weapons appeared
on the streets of New Orleans in a
moment of crisis the ability to deploy
mercenaries who are outside the legal
structure on the streets of our cities
brings us dangerously close to the
collapse of the Democratic state now
none of these movements no totalitarian
movement is going to come to power
unless there is a period of prolonged
instability and we don't have that now
but should we have I spent a year of my
life covering al-qaeda for the New York
Times and there was not an intelligence
official I interviewed here in Europe
who didn't speak about another
catastrophic terrorist attack on
American soil as an inevitability should
that moment occur should there be an
economic collapse should there be a
series of environmental disasters then
what's to prevent these Blackwater
operatives appearing from appearing on
the streets of Washington and that's the
old question which destroyed what was
left of the Roman Republic is who guards
the guards I just be curious to know
what inspired you to write the book and
to take up the
anger you know I come out I come out of
the church my father was probably the
greatest influence on my life a
Presbyterian pastor in upstate New York
had combined that deep moral probity no
alcohol in the man's where I grew up I
never heard my father swear we didn't
work on Sunday but with a commitment to
social justice which like Adams he
believed was an integral part of the
biblical message so that he was involved
in the civil rights movement I think
many people forget that in rural white
enclaves such as the one I grew up in in
early 1960s Martin Luther King was one
of the most hated men in America and
then went on to work in the anti-war
movement I remember when I was about 12
or 13 he told me that if I was the war
was still going on when I was 18 and I
was drafted he would go to prison with
me and I still carry this image of
sitting in a jail cell with my dad and
he died in 1995 but the last years of
his life were spent in the gay rights
movement his brother his youngest
brother my uncle was gay so he had a
real sensitivity of the pain of being a
gay man in America in the 1950s and 60s
I went to Colgate University there was
no gay and lesbian organization and when
my father by this time he had a church
in Syracuse found this out about an hour
away
he brought the gay speakers to my campus
this is in the 1970s and this led to
students confiding in my father after
several of these visits that they were
too uncomfortable coming out of the
closet and founding a gay and lesbian
organization on a campus and so he this
was a problem my dad solved by taking me
to lunch and telling me although I
wasn't gay that I had to found it so I
found him I used to walk into the dining
hall and the guy would take my card for
breakfast lunch or dinner and check it
off and hand it back to me and go [ __ ]
I made it my undergraduate mission to
seduce his girlfriend
uh I saw your piece in salon which I
like and but it occurs me it must be a
pretty tough sell to get media bookings
for this uh you know for this book tour
are you meeting a lot of resistance or
what's coming up no I'm getting bookings
um you know I've just started but I
think one of the things that surprised
me is why I'm not challenged more on the
use of the word fascism I mean it's a
loaded term I think generically the
movement fits I think when you read
people like packs Paxton I begin the
book for those of you have a copy with
Umberto eCos fourteen qualities that
make a blue shirt or black shirt
whatever that Italian fascist war you
know I mean and and Paxton
I think writes correctly and this is in
his book anatomy of fascism that you
know all societies carry within them
movements that essentially can be
defined as fascist he said that in our
past the Klu Klux Klan was probably the
most authentically fascist movement
created within American society so I
think they fit I mean I think that when
you look at the cult of masculinity the
war against intellectualism the
obsession with violence as a way to
cleanse the world you know it there are
enough qualities within the movement to
generically call it but it's a loaded
word it brings up historical
connotations and you know these you know
fascist movements adopt indigenous
symbols and language which is something
you know it's it's there's a great book
shel bear witness by klemper victor
klemper who was a professor of Romance
languages I believe in Leipzig Jewish
and lost his post and did sort of the
first literary critique of the Nazi
Party or National Socialism and he
understood how these movements hollow
out words so that they use a comforting
kind of vocabulary they use symbols that
that make us feel as if there's a kind
of continuity
but they turn these symbols in this
language to mean often things that are
diametrically opposed to what the words
have men in the past I mean - Orwell
gets this with this kind of you know
pieces war kind of thing you see it in
the word Liberty if you notice that
President Bush after he gave his
nationwide address calling for the
escalation of troop numbers in Iraq and
did he didn't end by saying god Bless
America he ended by talking about that
force which gives us Liberty I forget
the exact phrase that Liberty is an
extremely loaded word because Liberty
for people in the movement means the
Liberty that comes by giving your life
over to and submitting completely to
Jesus Christ
it means it's Liberty as submission so
that when we hear the word Liberty it
still continues to mean what we think it
is always meant but to the radical base
it's a message and it's not a message
and and you know Bush has an evangelical
speechwriter it's a message they
constantly send out this stream of coded
messages and I think when you read
Klemperer or or or well you understand
very well that corruption of language
that poisoning of the civil discourse
which always presages the rise of
totalitarian movements been arguments
that numbers the CRISPR voting against
economic interest how do they define the
Restonic interest yeah that's you know
Thomas Frank's argument I I don't think
these people come from you know by the
time they're wrapped in the embrace of
this movement by the time they spend all
day long sitting in front of Sky Angel
or TBN or the 700 club they have already
been removed from the reality-based
world you know I was I attended a
seminar for the book and I think it was
either Missouri or Kansas but it was
about it was a seminar for teachers for
Chris teachers and Christian schools and
it was instructing them on how to teach
the process of creation
now you only need to read the book of
Genesis once to understand that the
writers of the book of Genesis thought
the earth was flat they only not only
thought the earth was flat they thought
there were rivers above and below us in
the creation story God creates light on
the first day and the Sun on the fourth
day so this creates obviously the quest
obvious question what happened for the
four days and according to the
instructor God created a temporary light
now there's nothing in the Bible that
even hints that God created a temporary
light for that four-day period but I
think it's in those kinds of details
that you find how desperate these people
are to hang on to this magical belief
system which is what it is you know that
the writers of the book of Genesis knew
nothing about the process of creation
what they that's not why they wrote the
book of Genesis they were writing about
the purpose of creation and that is
something that I believe they did know a
lot about it's why the Bible for me is
worth reading but but when people live
in a non reality based world when they
believe that a dinosaurs existed with
Adam and Eve I was at the twenty five
million dollar Creation Museum in
Kentucky which i think is opening in a
couple weeks and you know they have a
replica of the Garden of Eden Adam and
Eve are naked but they're turned in such
a way that you can't see breasts or
anything and and they have dinosaurs
there and visitors are explained that in
those in the Garden of Eden dinosaurs
were safe because they only ate plants
including t-rex and the reason he had
long teeth is so he could open coconuts
this is all real and and that it was
only after the fall that dynasty no
source became meat-eaters there was a
replica of Noah's Ark and of course that
thorny question of how you fit dinosaurs
on an ark and and that was solved
because Noah only put baby Dino
on the ark I mean you know when you get
down to that kind of level you realize
the absolute absurdity of the belief
system but while it's absurd that's all
these people have and and part of the
rage that they feel towards critics
comes from this fear of being pushed
back in the reality-based world in which
they could not cope the world that
betrayed them
the world that they yearn to be
destroyed and that's essentially what
this obsession with apocalyptic violence
is it is about destroying the world that
betrayed them along with all of the
people who betrayed them many people do
you think are just fellow travelers on
this versus real ah hard believers I
must say my own family we range from
hard believers to let's get along at
Thanksgiving dinner to me right well you
know all radical movements we know from
writers like crane Briton in his great
book anatomy of a revolution are tiny
that hardcore ruthless manipulative the
James Dobson's of the world
I mean single percentage numbers it's
small I mean what were the Bolsheviks 1%
but they count on the sympathy of 80 to
100 million people who define themselves
as evangelicals and I think what's so
fascinating for me about this movement
is that these people are not
fundamentalists and they're not
evangelicals
I mean fundamentalists have always
called on followers to remove them
traditionally to remove themselves from
the contaminants of secular society to
shun political politics because it's
dirty traditional evangelical leaders
like Billy Graham always called on their
followers to be wary of political power
Graham himself was badly burned by Nixon
this is a new animal we have not seen
this before we can we continue and of
course they propagate those terms we
continue to use terms like
fundamentalist to describe someone like
Jerry Falwell he's not a fundamentalist
Pat Robertson is not an evangelical what
we're seeing is something a mutation
something radically different we're
seeing in proper terms dominionists
people who believe that they have been
given a God they have a god-given right
to run this country and ultimately to
run the globe and that that that's
that's a that's a you know of a huge
there's a huge chasm between these
people and and what we've seen in
American society in the past given what
you were describing of the determination
of Christian Right the funds of Dobson's
the Robertsons the fall Wells to impose
their belief system on the society to
bring the government the fact that they
have been you know packing the federal
judiciary there the hundreds of millions
of dollars you're talking about the fact
they're in the white house me seems to
me they're fairly far along on this path
we're not in a theocracy but they're
fairly far along given along with the
things like the military commissions act
the legalization of torture and holding
people mean all these different measures
they've taken and then you you pose the
question what would happen if it was
some other 9/11 incident or some other
kind of catastrophe and the question I
wanted to pose is based on your study of
this whole movement and where you see
this going doesn't mean to me doesn't
like you have a whole lot of time so
from your viewpoint
what do you see doing now to stop this
well the question is how much time do we
have how far along is this movement what
worries me I mean I think that we're in
a situation that's somewhat similar to
the 1930s where again we had a period
where many many people in this society
had essentially been pushed out of
mainstream society there were powerful
progressive forces within the press
which of course had a kind of
multiplicity that it no longer has I
think it's if I'm corrected 80% of
America's newspapers are controlled by
six or eight corporations broadcast
journalism as virtually doesn't exist
anymore with the exception of c-span a
few other NPR but there's not much out
there
um and I worry that we don't have the
power organized power in the event of a
crisis to stand up against them that
there may be a kind of individual
reaction I mean I don't think most
Americans I don't think even most
evangelicals want to live in the kind of
America these people want to create but
of course by then by the time they find
out it will be too late and one has to
look at the you know the transformation
of any society at a moment of radical
change I mean Iran would be a good
example when when Ayatollah Khomeini
came back secular Iranians were cheering
him in the street the notion in 1979
that Iranian women would be forced to
cover their heads was laughable but
there is a slow gradual almost
imperceptible erosion that totalitarian
movements make I mean the Nazis did it
it took them a very long time Claudia
quinces book the Nazi conscience is a
great read or Sebastian Hoffner is
define Hitler you understand that this
is a long process and by the time people
wake up it's too late that process is
clearly underway without question and
and after writes after the burning of
the Reichstag and Hitler's declaring of
martial law how I think hundreds of
thousands of Germans poured out into the
street in protest but there was no
leadership the opposition was bankrupt
in fact the the Social Democrats fled to
a villa they had rented in Lugano and
Switzerland and without that that
opposition without that the ability of
leaders to stand up even the majority
who opposes this move is essentially
rendered impotent and I fear that we
keep moving down this path and I don't
find very many people standing up and
wringing the kind of alarm bells
certainly very few within the Democratic
Party which should be our
position well web is I think web gets it
at least from my point of view and I
think some of I think web gets the the
how dangerous this economic dislocation
and the creation of an American
oligarchy is to our democratic system
and that's not a new thought I mean
Plutarch wrote about this he said that
disparity between the rich and the poor
is the worst ailment that can be set any
Republic lucidity 'he's understood it
when athens empire expanded and and many
of the neighboring greek states did not
want to live under athenian control and
athens had to impose greater and greater
tyranny vicinities wrote the tyranny we
impose on others we will eventually
impose on our self which is of course
what happened it was the death of
Athenian democracy and I think when we
look carefully at how we deal now with
the rest of the world we as a country
are essentially capable of only speaking
to people outside our gates in the
language of violence this language of
violence is going to be brought home
already is being brought home look at
our prison system so that I and I you
know having spent two decades of my life
outside the United States the disparity
between what I left and what I came back
to is stark and frightening thank you
very much